you're you're now part of Spanish
nobility right so this is it is it dama
Longoria now I am dama lady Longoria
I will introduce you from now on what
does this mean it's like it's like um
you know one of the highest honors you
get from Spain this is from Spain so my
family originally is from Spain oh right
so
um so is this to do with your ancestors
yes with my ancestors so there's like
Caballeros and Damas and so now I'm dama
Longoria that's so cool do you get into
that like about ancestry yeah like that
yeah my mother got really into it I was
like you're a little weird about it and
then I got weird about it I think it's
cool too have you done the well I did it
before because I I don't know why but
like many reasons I won't say on TV but
but I ended up I ended up because we're
all getting swabbed all the time so I
was like whatever so I did the 23 being
all the ancestors yeah I found all this
stuff it's cool I mean it's great for
for health indicators exactly yeah
predisposed to Alzheimer's or DeMent
like it's good it's interesting that
your sibling is different from like that
different from you like yeah from a
different percentage Yeah a parent it's
yeah it's like they get more of a gene
than yeah yeah I'm basically adopted so
I'm the youngest of four girls and I
look nothing like my brothers and
sisters and I mean I have no brothers
what am I talking about yeah so you
don't look like them I don't look like
they don't like them either
you got four girls in the house that's a
lot four girls one bathroom yeah oh my
God okay okay Poor Dad that was like me
on that the only Intel I have on that is
whenever I was on American Idol they had
us live in a house like 20 years ago and
all the girls were just I'm just a very
I'm a tomboy and so I don't wear makeup
if I'm not working I don't do I don't
I'm just not very girly yeah and so
anyway I there you know it was like
fighting for her makeup time or
bathrooms or whatever that's the only
Intel I have I was like oh my gosh this
gets hardcore like who gets in there
first you know what I'm saying it was
like I was always happy to like not even
make time for it but anyway
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]